i'm back baby that's right
you missed me feel free to type down an
essay how much you missed me in the
comments right now
please ignore the glasses okay this is
not some sort of fashion statement that
i'm back and now i wear glasses no i
just forgot to order contact lenses
thank you very much although why has no
one told me that in these glasses i look
like harry potter's dead seriously
this is [ __ ] i don't want to wear
these it's what i'm saying no i hate it
if you're wondering what i've been doing
since i weigh
yeah i don't know
been reading
and trying to learn japanese and it's
impossible i don't know i'm trying and
that's about it
i got nothing interesting but let's see
what's going on with you guys
in the pewdiepie subreddit uh and to be
fair i miss you guys too a little bit
tiny bit oh oh okay i've realized you
know we're on year what is it 11 12 now
i need to stay relevant obviously
and the best way to stay relevant as
everyone knows creating drama that's why
instead of trying to focus on one person
like i've done in the past t-series coco
melon you know those have been huge
failures in the end because youtube
comes in and says no you can't you're
bullying
we're gonna start drama with everyone
you can't stop me youtube therefore i
found this website called random youtube
and we will start drama with today
braincraft worst channel i've ever seen
you can't wear your is there so
[Music]
who wears their brain outside their head
that's the dumbest thing i've ever seen
bro you don't even have a million subs
yet cringe so yeah go and
no
don't do anything it was a stupid joke
i've stopped that already
anyway let's check out the way he's so
lucky he met pewdiepie out in the public
except this jacksepticeye that's
hilarious excuse me excuse me are you
pewdiepie
is that beauty filter jesus christ god
damn smoky silky cheeks on jack's eye me
trying to blow uh tnt using a youtube
tutorial after just likes for remove
yes
we're never complaining about the
dislikes being removed youtube
never it's the worst thing ever done
this happened almost three years ago but
i'm still unable to forget this
masterpiece you know that you can jump
off a high point and place water
right before you hit the ground this is
true any fall damage
as such
[Music]
dream better watch out dream better
watch out i guess the new thing is to
build a boat mid-air right an important
photo
i remember this we were playing smash i
think
oh damn time [ __ ] flies dude jesus
jack looks so different he looks more
like a
leprechaun in this one i will say that
i don't get it
oh i get it did everyone stare at her
ass jesus christ
[ __ ] men dude
if i swore in his video like i would
know that
a lot wait 6189
or none
[Music]
what if i swear now and then click six
are you
kidding me
why is that on tick tock god damn it
when you realize the next enemy of
subscribers is going to be mr peace
i guess i'm gonna have to start my next
drama with mr b's
diss track coming now i'm joking i'm not
gonna do it so our power is out our only
light is our pewdiepie chair and it kind
of look you found the secret achievement
peepee chair
hell yeah
well done proud of you
yeah i keep forgetting that it lets up
the chair lights up guys i don't know if
you know that it lights up it's pretty
epic pewdiepie confirmed what we
suspected about his relationship with
mark
hell yeah
thank you
uh oh my god mango makes videos here
after months i finally finished
pewdiepie melody
okay
uh-huh
because i remember you made like a nice
new version
oh
beautiful
[Music]
oh wow
got a whole orchestra
okay
sure
it's got that swedish uh tone to it i
touched my eye and i guess i had
something in my finger i can't
i'm not crying i actually
i mean it is beautiful
oh god damn it
okay critical waiting for peace to
contact him to host meme review
what am i
i'm allowed to collaborate critical
don't get me wrong but meme review
there's no good memes lately and i'm
crying over it apparently it's what god
damn it what was on my finger
did you guys see anything here's an idea
memes are bad right now right everyone
notices we're not doing meme review is
it cause and effect which one came first
chicken egg you tell me it was nice
meeting you pewdiepie
likewise
my pleasure
yeah
there was an announcement youtube shut
down uh what was it called uh youtube
shut down original content group which
means
rip scare pewdiepie once and for all it
was the only thing that could have saved
it scare pewdiepie season two so there's
uh there's just no hope there's no hope
it's a shame um uh it was a cool uh cool
project and i'm happy to have been part
of it there's a lot of talent people on
that
group of youtube
that i got to interact with
[Applause]
what happened
[Music]
pretty much i didn't see it though so
cringe norway is so weak i don't even
notice their invasion
epic cringe
so finland and sweden might join natto
now i think listen i'm not keeping up
with world politics
russia is [ __ ] about something i
don't know i don't whatever so we might
have to accept norway as part of the
well even better this is what i said
alliance [ __ ] nato i don't know what i'm
talking i shouldn't say anything this is
a joke everything i say joke everything
i ever said joke you know what i need i
need one of those signs hold up i'm like
this is a joke sorry
enjoy this picture fizz generally pissed
that scary piece okay
i think it was pretty clear i definitely
needed a break jesus christ i was
streaming
and chat was just so [ __ ] annoying
and i can't hold it in anymore the
backseat gamers let me play the goddamn
game away i want to play it
i don't need to know every single detail
about it
shut the [ __ ] up
anyway
i would never even think of a woman okay
the true idea of being nice let's go a
woman she doesn't want to move to an
island and live like a hermit her most
of my life is punishment let's
this is indoctrinated footage
cgi don't believe cgi cb cg line get it
so i changed the line i think you got
the joke
it was a joke look at this styling
swedish beast i look without glasses
although it is blurry so i can't really
see look at this harry potter's
bully ass dan sorry
yeah that's me
[Music]
okay see that's how i feel without my
glasses
all black suit just like my wedding baby
let's go this english youtuber called
jack sucks that i bought both the
hundred mill play button and the box
finally reunited them together yeah so
apparently lizard sold his which
you know
he could have hang on to it a little
longer i mean i didn't expect him to
keep it forever but i think it's fair
enough i don't really care you know how
everyone is like oh there's one for
there's a person for everyone
not no no no
i think most people aren't ready for a
relationship because they have their own
issues to deal with and when you're in a
relationship those issues will come to
life onto the other person and maybe
that person is very capable to help you
get through those okay it can happen but
a lot of time it just becomes this
really toxic
horrible
nasty situation where people's lives get
wasted or ruined and
i don't think it's fair black pill
pewdiepie jesus christ yeah there you go
you must love self before loving other
or not i don't care
i haven't used the new texture pack in a
while okay that's epic hello
i am back
good old stefano man god damn that man
you piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] you
dead to me
do you understand i will [ __ ] kill
you
why was i posting so much on instagram
back in the day can't hear can talk can
touch can't go to japan oh yeah that's
right i'm still here
that's cool
[Laughter]
uh
i'm gonna
go out of line here and announce that
the pandemic is over because i am back
i'm back now you can stop worrying about
it i've you're welcome
i've cured everyone
i fixed it there you go there's no more
illness in the world uh
i'm holding the joke sign herpes is
still a thing though i try okay i call
them can you do something about that
they said no but they're working on it
everything else i fixed that you're
welcome
all the big pete's explaining the ass
his piece is struggling to get 10 fps
i need a new computer don't i i don't
feel like it i don't want to shut up oh
[ __ ] 300k goddamn butt
bam bada bam skip it air
like the red shades that gave me very
sleek
very cute
i should use can i borrow this as in
steal it for my like stream
[Music]
uh joe and cordero 6565 great name great
name we'll never forget pewdiepie
purposely having one of the most
disliked videos on youtube removing the
disney camp i'm never gonna give it up
you're always gonna let me down
uh my sister watching sniper wolf me
watching pewdiepie i barely see them
having a laugh
average sniper wolf fan pewdiepie
enjoyer
you know what i don't trip on sniperwolf
she i'm sure video great okay
i don't have to [ __ ] on everyone i don't
honestly i don't have a problem with
sniper wolf but braincraft
more like lamecraft
sleeping with friends you're not
supposed to do that that's bad advice
hey you got the reference
nice
you know we had all this music lined up
right at least four or five songs ready
i just
this killed me man they just took it
down man bro i'm not dead
no i appreciate that
thank you
[Laughter]
yes
reject modernity embrace tradition the
industry what what why you're going to
tell me there's a problem with the
industrial revolution now
i don't believe that oh we got another
one hell yeah oh
so smooth so silky
i want to lick that
i can't be the only one shut up that one
fourth grader showing off his cool new
toy that he stole from a first grader
what google says about pewdiepie might
think three billion i mean i wouldn't be
here for if i didn't know i wouldn't be
here i'd be on mars with elon musk
i just realized i'm not gonna have space
to bring back everyone
okay
all right that was fun it's almost like
i enjoyed doing this
but you know everyone needs break once
in a while thank you for being
respectful and appreciative i appreciate
you guys likewise thank you for
subscribing that's a great way to
support channel
and uh you know what you don't have to
buy anything i feel like uh i've been
selling you guys enough stuff buy your
grandma some flowers how about that
okay brofist